yo what to do with your boy pila
check me on the boulet kev podcast
all right man boo lakehead podcast
special guest
pilo man what's up man my guy what's up
man how's everything man everybody looks
good man how are you doing man i'm
blessed but i you know i can't complain
um
yo i want to talk i've been going to the
bay a lot lately yeah i've been going
like at least once a month yeah
and
[ __ ] is kind of crazy in the bay right
now yeah it's a little
it's a little
at least in the city yeah
the cvs's the walgreens that [ __ ] ain't
open yeah it's still it's a little
gnarly it's a little gnarly up there i'm
in my hotel and i'm like man i need to
go get some bottles of water some snacks
and [ __ ] i'm like oh cool there's a cvs
right here i walk up this [ __ ] is closed
and like at like 9 00 a.m on a [ __ ]
monday again i should should be getting
hit out there yeah cause i guess out
there is um
if you steal as long as it's under
999 dollars they can't really care
they can't prosecute you yes it's not
it's not really you feel me
so every like i've been seeing videos of
just homeless dudes on bikes just
rolling up into the cvs they're just
getting what they need for the day
the employees can't do nothing yeah they
can't do nothing bro so like
what are they gonna do bro the base
always but and then obviously the
bipping i feel like it's getting i mean
it's always been a thing yeah it's
always been a thing it's like i like
people from out of town just like
come and just get a rent a car to leave
all their [ __ ] in to rent a car
and then you know i'm saying people i
think people even like people are
looking for rental cars because they
know that people aren't like they're
just driving and they're not even
they're not even knowing what's going on
yeah for people who don't know what
bipping is explain because this is a bay
area yeah
it's like
it's like you're like breaking in the
car just like a little
yeah they just like switch
break the windows or whatever and just
see what you got in there
and you know what i'm saying that's why
i like if you feel in the bay make sure
you not like
if you out parking somewhere you don't
leave nothing in the car visible or like
you know what i'm saying because even if
it's like a
some type of like wire or something like
it's like it's liable to
to get bipped or something you know
they're gonna take something was it
always
um
like obviously you grew up in the bay's
has that always been like a part of the
culture out there um i
yeah low-key but like
i feel like it it's even more than like
now probably within the probably like
ramped up in the last like few years
so but like yeah i mean but it's just
it's just never
like
it's never good to just like leave your
[ __ ] there anywhere i like i don't l
like i could be anywhere like i remember
one time we was in japan
and um we were like shooting this like
we were shooting something like a video
or something and the dude just like
it was like oh yeah you could just leave
like yeah just like it's like a 20 000
camera in the car he just like left it
he's like oh we're just going to go
inside just into the museum and [ __ ] and
just kick it or whatever and i was like
he's about to just leave that there he's
like yeah it's like it's good
and i was thinking to myself i was like
oh my god like i've been through there's
so much trauma that i've been through
that i can't even do this like i can't
even like i was like bro we can't just
leave this twenty thousand dollar camera
in the whip he's like yeah bruh japan
like it's good like
people not on that i got i got hit last
year for like someone followed me out of
the bank
and i parked right in front of the ups
store ran in to get something notarized
oh and they got it they got it they got
15 bands in cash oh my god and my
backpack with my laptop within seconds
yeah no you're cooked and ever since
then no matter where i go no i got my
backpack on oh bro straight up bro
but people are like yo you got i'm like
yeah i'm not playing out here i'm not
playing that's not a game because you
you really could get got
and that's and that's like and it's so
it happens in seconds bro
have you ever had someone like get your
car
like stole my car no no like like small
oh grab your shirt
windows broken
bro i remember i seen uh one of my
homies was like he had his whip bro and
he like we hopped out the car he he uh
we hopped out of the car and he parked
the ship
he rolled down all his windows
and we left
i was like hey i was like well why you
wrote down all your widows i said
brother so they could just so you feel
me so just they don't break my [ __ ] yeah
cause they might break your [ __ ] even if
you ain't got anything and then there's
another headache and that's a headache
and you got and then you gotta pay the
300. you might as well say i'm gonna
leave all my windows down
and look around you look around there's
nothing in the windows just don't break
the windows bro that's some real [ __ ] i
said
i said wow that's a life hack and that
is a life i said brother's really
futuristic
i like that because even if you don't
got nothing if they break your window
that's an insurance plan yeah like you
gotta it's damn near 300. off the wrist
rip and it's a headache you're riding
around with a busted window you got
glasses up your ass yeah like
yeah just know i'm gonna just roll all
my [ __ ] down just y'all can look through
i remember one time hop in still
yeah yeah you you're like no but they
don't really want to steal the car nah
of course no they don't want to steal
the car
bro i remember one time like
i was like we mean my friends was like
out here like smoke we was like we was
in oakland we were smoking
and like this car pull up we like in a
parking lot this car pulls up
and he broke oh hey did y'all whip
i was like we were like no no
but he walks around the whole car just
kind of like looks inside looks inside
looks inside and he goes to the next car
looks inside looks inside looks inside
he goes all right
dips off
wow i said oh man they're even polite
about it
they're getting more polite about it he
said this your car i was like no no no
he's like all right
that's crazy i said man man look at that
bippin has bippin has you know evolved
it's evolved well i saw that like
there's like a
a serious reward amount if you if you
find someone who's bipping
they put like a serious dollar amount on
like yes yes
it's like six figures i want to say it's
something stupid is it like a hundred or
something i think it's a hundred
thousand dollars bro holy [ __ ] look at
that
that's crazy what is that is that like
in san francisco in san francisco
yeah brad like yeah that's just getting
pretty intense out there yeah
and then even like you know these mall
runs where all these people you saw a
video bro
the cops pulled up and you know what it
is though it's it's it's the government
bro that you feel me what does that mean
that's a very blanket statement it does
bro i mean most people government but
people out here starving bro they they
took away the whole edd out of me and
unemployment you know what i mean by
like what people are supposed to do bro
it's christmas time
they gotta say this
there's an idea
that those people
could get a job
yeah but where are the jobs at though
everywhere
i mean everybody is hiring yeah you
could go to in-n-out burger and get a
bag right now hey man i drove by del
taco on hollywood way over here and it
said twenty dollars an hour now hiring
please
i might go to death talker if they tired
[ __ ] i don't be doing [ __ ] during the
day by the way taco
i would like to point out del taco gets
a bad rep but i think i'm a fan you're a
fan of delta well so you mean to tell me
in the morning to dawtaka at 3am of
course
if my choices are del taco or jack in
the box what about taco or taco bell
i'll talk about all that okay okay come
on i'm not a crazy person
i was like damn no but del taco hit the
spot a certain you know you know what's
crazy i feel like del taco's uh um they
got good fries it i i don't really the
thing is like growing up right we we
never really had dill tacos that's nice
the nearest del taco was maybe like sac
or like fresno or something like that so
like we never really got del taco so
when i when i came down here to l.a and
it was hella delta i was like damn is
this [ __ ] like lit
or like it's good enough like yeah i
mean yeah
obviously there's a lot of them so it's
obviously good enough what's the food
that was everywhere in the bay that
isn't everywhere in l.a
um nations
don't even know what that is nations
it's just like um
it's like a burger joint but it's like
what they do they do breakfast it's like
a diner but they pause and [ __ ] they
pause if you ever go to the bay
go to a nations
you feel me get you a banana cream pie i
love banana cream pie it's my favorite
kind of pie but negative a banana cream
pie
you feel me get you a side of chili
cheese fries
just signing up for diarrhea yeah no
it's it's mud though it's for so much
like it's my slime for sure but i'm just
saying like like you get you a little
slice get your little
uh chili cheese fries man you're gonna
be for me that maybe get you a little dr
pepper or something you know that's a
way um break down kind of like the
geography of the bay because i feel like
everyone thinks of the bay who's not
from there and they think of san
francisco or oakland but there's vallejo
richmond there's so many different areas
and i feel like loki a lot of the sounds
kind of like you can kind of tell
yeah yeah i i think like you know
the the bay is like it's made of like
it's massive yeah it's big but it's like
it's like a hella small cities and small
pockets that like all
combine and meet each other but yeah
like together there's some there there's
certain [ __ ] that you know that sounds
like is from the the surface club you
know what i'm saying or some [ __ ] that
sounds like oakland and some [ __ ] that
sounds like all this and vallejo [ __ ]
but now it's just like but it's also
like
there's there's these pockets are like
even people from sac you know i'm saying
to sacramento and then like the people
in the valley like stockton and no no
stockton's booming yeah like there's a
lot of like no [ __ ] but it all stems
from the like the bad music you know
what i'm saying like the the essence of
like i drove through stockton
one night
with uh with brian sampson who's an old
old og in the game shout out to uh was
it dj uh flip cj fly fly dj fly dj fly
dj fly i'm in i'm in san francisco and i
got a flight in the morning back to l.a
and he's like man don't make me drive
back to because he was driving back
she's like don't make me drive back to
la alone
he's like just ride with me bro real one
sorry you slid
you know what i got you bro we're a
[ __ ] real one so i'll [ __ ] fall
asleep in the front seat right and i
wake up
he's like yeah get up i'm like where are
we at he's like we're driving through
stockton i want to show you where i grew
up
it's like it's like one in the morning
and we're in the [ __ ] like
projects of stockton california
unbeknownst to me when i wake up and i
don't realize how hot it is where i'm at
and i'm like bro i didn't sign up for
the [ __ ] stockton hood detours bro
the swamp stories and nonetheless
[ __ ] was real out there no bro stock
didn't it get real for sure for real out
there it really get real out there
shouts out to stockton and in sacramento
too i mean i know
because like you know a lot of people
it's it's wild i'll hear people
slip up and say they're from the bay but
they're from sacramento
that [ __ ] happens bro yeah i mean but
like bro like like for me
like people be like oh stacks off the
bay and
like bro like
it's all in northern california for me
right you know what i'm saying and like
you know like i've there's people in
zach that i really really [ __ ] with you
know and there's people stopping that i
really really [ __ ] with but they that
you know the same but the the influence
is you know what i'm saying it's fr it's
all from the bay but right you feel me
it's like it's all gone because it's
like it's not you you're not gonna say
you don't [ __ ] with your cousin you know
what i'm saying i don't [ __ ] with some
of my cousins but yeah like it's like
bro it's like we failed like i'll be
like why am i going to distance myself
from you maybe your cousin's a mega
person
jesus christ that's when you might just
yourself i'm just saying well they're
still your cousin yeah but like yeah
like we're still friends on facebook you
know what i mean but like
he wants to dizzy yourself that's like
god damn it's my cousin qa9 what the
[ __ ] going on here
oh god
jesus christ
anyway yo so this new record you got has
40 has la russel lana la russell is
someone who i think has got a lot of
promise coming out of vallejo
i love his movement i love how he cuts
everyone in on everything he's got a
real just dope mindset when it comes to
his music [ __ ] yeah um
talk about like just how did you guys
initially link up because he's been
doing this thing for a minute yeah yeah
he's been doing this thing for a minute
um
and i like i think i've seen one of his
uh you know like the the gun company
videos
and i was like and i see it and i was
like man that's like you know
[Music]
most importantly like for him like he
started his like own [ __ ] right like you
know what i'm saying it wasn't like
um
like he didn't get it from like from no
one else it just kind of like he was
like you know what i'm finna just step
and i'm just gonna do what i do
and
and like
seeing that i was like you know i can
recognize when someone's just stepping
out and just being like you know i'm
just like i'm owning my [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying because like that's
something that i do you know
that i've identified with myself so i'm
like oh i got i got identified with that
and you know i'm saying
i just like want to show them some
respect you know i'm saying just like
you feel me like keep doing your [ __ ]
whenever you feel me like you come to
the house and just because that's the
first time working with 40
his first time yeah um i know i think he
has a song before that's a big deal man
yeah i think he has another song with 40
but yeah but like
yeah like you know what i'm saying i
think for me it's just like i wanted to
be able to like
on this song like obviously
bring in like ushering someone new you
know what i'm saying to to a lot of
people and then all and then on top
bring in
40 which is like another
layer of
music you know what i'm saying or fans
of you know what i'm saying that
obviously bringing my fans
so it's like it's another like i think
it's important too because i feel like
in the bay there's like a track record
of artists doing the same thing like 40
did that
g-eazy did a good job of that yeah you
know helping just try to showcase yeah
she had the rest of the world shout out
to jail for like you feel me like
because he he did that for us you know
what i'm saying and 40 did that for you
know what i'm saying for other people
but like yeah like i think for jeezy did
that pretty well so like i mean like i
just want to keep it you feminine keep
it alive keep it alive you know what i'm
saying so you've also um talk about some
of the soundtrack [ __ ] because you've
you've had some some dope moments yeah
on the space jam just yeah man like
shout out to archie man for for putting
that together how big of a deal because
i mean you're a basketball fan huge
basketball fan so and space jam is just
i mean we're kids our age it's like bro
i mean bro to be a part of like space
bro this is space jam bro it's insane
like space junior but like well like i
don't know how many times you've watched
space yeah a lot growing up i was a huge
jordan fanatic yeah like like i've
probably watched that movie how however
many times then i have all the toys
still yeah like low g toys
i remember uh
j uh jr's mom sold his uh his like big
ass michael jordan one for like five
bucks she was like yeah i just sold it
you know you're gonna put that on these
at least
general is so sick but yeah but um
um
but yeah like i mean just to be a part
of this is like brother like space i'm
gonna like stand to the test of time
you know what i'm saying we'll see about
this one though
bro i mean come on just as a film yeah
but i mean bro come on bro i'm gonna say
this about the film i think i think and
i'm a lebron stan my favorite player
ever
i think people were a little bit too
harsh on the movie bro because it's too
hot bro i actually thought the movie was
was was pretty like it was oh it was
[ __ ] incredible bro it was [ __ ]
cgi'd out like i actually thought it
wasn't bad oh what are people i was like
yeah when i watched it i was like
expecting it to be like a steaming pile
of dog [ __ ] and i was like yo this [ __ ]
is what i thought it was going to be oh
like people act like they're about to
get like denzel
bro come on
no people just know you know what not
even just lebron but people just be
hating
on everything everything we're in the
era of everyone everybody just be hating
brother like bro always voicing your
opinion like a [ __ ] hater yeah
especially about children and children
it's a [ __ ] children's movie bro yeah
come on bro
it's bugs bunny in there yeah like bro
what
like
like wow what are y'all bro come on
brother when they had the [ __ ]
from game of thrones in here i said oh
this [ __ ] is lit
up they put it all together and the
[ __ ] the white walkers in the
crowd and [ __ ] but this [ __ ] is lit no
but this is lit bro like come on bro
like [ __ ] be just
always just want to hate bro everyone
wants to hate just voicing your opinion
like a [ __ ] hater
you ever get like worried about like um
this cancel culture [ __ ] like saying the
wrong thing or someone digging up some
old tweets or something well
hey bro if he wasn't gonna [ __ ] with me
he wasn't gonna [ __ ]
i know like a few years ago i had to
like search certain words
not slurs just things that like you know
back in the day we used to say no homo a
lot you know what i'm saying like [ __ ]
like that bro i mean bro so i had to
like google my name with tweets and say
oh [ __ ] i gotta delete the no homo tweet
from 09
yeah i mean about
i mean just things change things changed
yeah hey bro
everybody ain't [ __ ] perfect but yeah
but i was talking to dame dash last week
and he was saying how he invented the
word pause
he said he invented it i don't know if
that's true or not well but he said he
invented pause and i who might have
questioned dame dash from harlem there's
dame this babe and um and he was like
yeah like you know [ __ ] would
come at me and cancel me now i invented
that [ __ ] work
brother dame dash bro his name you can't
keep he can't cancel name dashboard he's
too he's too good is there going to be
uh like obviously we're getting to the
end of the year is there a body of work
coming from you top of the year or what
what's what's next yeah yeah that's kind
of kind of what i'm looking for so it's
like maybe like springtime you know
that's kind of where i like how done is
the album
i mean
i could i could drop it today
[Music]
any other features
we got some cool things going on we got
some cool things going on we got some
cool stuff going on okay man filipinos
running [ __ ] right now shout out sweetie
sweetie
shout out to sweetie we got some things
going on she got a mcdonald's meal bro
come on stop playing stop playing with
the queen well i saw sweetie had a
mcdonald's me outside don't play with
the queen her management is on point
stop playing with party ain't got
mcdonald's oh god
i said no got mcduck come on nicki don't
got mcdonald's sweetie got her own meal
come on stop playing with the goat stop
playing with the goat good for her her
team put that play together come on bro
we we not really we if and we don't put
enough respect on cbd name bro i don't
disagree i think she's dope she she's
awesome man she's killing it yeah she is
killing it it's killing it
have you guys worked together or any any
you know that's coming soon too
who knows man so you and sweetie she's
on the album
my goodness
this guy's a private investigator
we got the pi here i like that so
sweetie's on the album
hey it's only right you guys finally
worked together i'm glad to hear what's
happening but that that's that's family
yeah yeah what's the song like she's
family man she's awesome man
she's that's family
so the record what's it like
who knows man you know has sweetie ever
wrapped over a pillow
it's folk it's folk music is there a
sweetie song or is there is there a
sweetie is there sweetie vocals over
pillow production that exists in the
world right now on a hard drive yeah
yeah there yeah there's there's a few
a few there's a few i like that there's
a few you guys do the trade one on her
is one on yours
we try you know we just we're just
trying to put one plus one equal two
that's what we're just trying to do
we're trying to put one plus one and
make it equal two that's what we mean
naturally that would make sense forever
so you know that's just what happens
you know
when the real ones connect wait hold on
time to stop the interview because we
got to talk about our good folks at odd
socks man listen if you go to
oddssoxofficial.com that's
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev all right at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them you know
i'm gonna lie to you man i was uh so
nico um my producer nico uh you know
nico yeah that's family he's a filipino
bambino you know what i'm saying heavy
hitter come on heavy hitter uh
he got me really excited to try
the filipino fast food joint what's it
called jollibee jollibee right so
they delivered some jolly bee to me what
did you get no i didn't order they just
delicious now obviously i don't know
where they drove this [ __ ] from
but it was not fresh oh yeah i got you
but it was uh
it was like spaghetti uh and a piece of
chicken yeah yeah yeah i was just a
little
disappointed yeah
i mean me personally
i never really like
i had to reheat it you know yeah i never
really rocked with the with the with the
jolly bee spaghetti
personally i [ __ ] with the with the
gravy and the rice at the jolly bee and
then i [ __ ] with the spicy chicken the
spicy chips oh that's awesome bro you
gotta get the the fresh
spicy chicken that [ __ ] is crazy
yo when you went back to the philippines
um and you shot the that video was it in
your dad's old neighborhood yeah what
was that like
bro insane bro and you know what's crazy
i actually just see yesterday i i flew
up to the uh to the bay for the for the
day i saw that and i yeah
my grandma she's turning 100 this week
shout out to grandma that's huge man
yeah bro insane she's turning a a whole
honey century bro honeybun wow
she's seen it all well she really does
she was born 1921. she got so much gain
bro i was literally just i was like bro
imagine how much gain she obtained i
want to bring your grandma on the
podcast i want to talk to somebody who's
out old on my podcast just like yo
you've seen it all you lived through so
much but she lived through so much [ __ ]
and you feel me she still she's still
mopping you feel me she still go to
church every wednesday and sunday you
know what i'm saying
she's still praying for me every day you
know what i'm saying so she the one
that's covering me you know what i'm
saying
so yeah no but yeah but anyways but yeah
but like that's just insane and just to
be able to like
see like where you know
my lineage stem from
you know what i'm saying like if
one wrong move
or one
step in another direction i could have
been still out there still there still
out there being like one of those kids
like running around the neighborhood
with no shoes on
and you know what i'm saying with some
like little sandals on you know i'm
saying but
shout out to pops for bossing up bossed
up oh i heard if you
is it true like if you do drugs out
there they'll like kill yourself oh yeah
no they're they mopping fools well even
weed
but we like anything even if you're
suspected yes you don't even got to be
proven
they'll kill you bro suspected
they'll just smoke you
smoke
[ __ ] is getting mopped up
that's crazy no yeah no isn't um
manny pacquiao trying to be the
president next i think so i think he's
he's running for office or something
he's doing something in there i heard he
kind of a wild boy too low-key i mean
but yeah like i mean
everybody in the government really on
that [ __ ]
on all sides
because i feel like pacquiao is like
obviously the most like i bet he's the
most famous legendary famous
but you know like that's kind of how a
rock out there like you could like be a
you could you could you could like
dinner be an actor and then just like if
you really didn't president and then you
could just turn you could you saying you
could be the president yeah one day i
could be
you know i'm not real i'm not ruling it
out oh wow i'm not ruling it out would
you would you reverse the drug laws
we the thing is we on the campaign right
now
[Music]
which campaign are we on we're on the
campaign with the life campaign you know
what i'm saying with this this could be
the campaign to becoming the president
all right then we on it then we own it
you won't die if you smoke weed
no but but that's how it is in a lot of
like uh like i flew into singapore
singapore i heard his like don't mean
his country right no bro bro
when you fly in the singapore bow
they stamp your [ __ ] they they give you
a little card you it's stamp and it says
uh
any any drug i forgot what it says is it
singapore and indonesia that's like that
about anything with drugs and drugs and
[ __ ] you cook
yeah i don't know if it's singapore or
indonesia well one of those countries
supposed to be like so clean like the
streets are like oh yeah
no single portions bro singapore is
beautiful bro right here it's like it's
like uh you can't litter you can't do
anything crazy you can't even like i
don't think you could chew gum out there
there's no like gum or something like
that or something there's a lot of hot
breath yeah [ __ ]
humming
but yeah but like bro that shit's insane
out there it's like everything's like
new
yo talk about your relationship with the
niners obviously the niners and the a's
have really kind of you know
you've you
know
you've had situations where you've
really like and it you know
embedded yourself in with like the local
teams in the city like
i mean i i think i think it's just a
it's a it's a blessing just to be able
to do that you know what i'm saying like
especially like
growing up in the area like those teams
like in the sports mean so much to us up
there
and just to be able to like uh
for those
huge organizations that are like you
know huge brands in the world right
right you know for them to recognize
what i got going on in the area you know
and what i got going on period
and just for them for them to
acknowledge acknowledge what we got
going on is like
that's just insane to me you know i
think growing up and watching those
games and just being like yeah like bro
like that's the you know what i'm saying
just to be a be able to go up there and
do my thing and just be who i am in that
realm
is
that shit's insane this is still like
insane to me you know what i would like
to hear what right now stunner man's got
big stepping big stepping
everyone's doing the big stepping
pillow on the remix
look at that wow dude can we make that
happen bro bro
are you are you like uh what
is it happening
bro you're the [ __ ] police i'm just
telling you what i want to hear bro
you're the [ __ ] police
jesus christ jesus christ jesus christ
bro why bro why are you like that what
do you mean well you're
bro he has the wiretap
he's tapping the phones well i feel like
you're a big niner guy this guy's step
in the phone you're a big niner guy this
is like the niner anthem yes that's it
yeah one thousand sounds out the stunner
man
we're still with it even mixing from the
bengals is hitting the big step in there
come on
it makes it from the bay man yeah that
makes sense come on man you know shout
out to joe mitchell that's that's the
family so you're going to be on the
remix
who knows bro well then why would i be
referred to as the feds for bringing up
the whole nose bro who [ __ ] knows
who knows bro
big step in remix who knows
maybe get the gang back together for no
bro this guy is crazy bro
well bay area a little love like little
barry remix what wow this guy this guy
does it man this guy
you see all these plaques and all this
is it coming out
y'all would get debo santa to pull up to
the video should there should be a movie
movie shout out to the depot that's he
going crazy right now going crazy insane
running back my thing is when does he
become eligible in fantasy as a running
back so we could just swatch swift
switch i know but does he get more
points when he actually rushes i don't
[ __ ] know like you know what i'm
saying like when the receiver actually
rushes or i don't know
let me ask you this how do you feel
about kyle shanahan
i think
i think he's uh would you like him to
big step out of the niners man
sometimes i just think he be you know
he he sometimes he got to remember who
he is you know what i'm saying and there
that's for everybody right right you
know i'm saying everybody needs to you
know i'm saying he's
he's he's called games where he's just
really called games and really went
crazy and there's some games he just
he just doesn't do that
yeah i feel like when you guys played us
this year and he was going for it on all
those fourth downs bro that was i was
like this is amazing this is amazing i
was like yeah keep going for it we're
just gonna keep stuff with y'all this is
what happened bro but i mean but
we were close that was that was one of
the better games it was the trey lance
game yeah that was the trey lens game
bro yeah that was one of the better
games
how do you feel about trey you feeling
good yeah i feel like i'm just you
trying to get jimmy g the [ __ ] up out of
here i'm feeling great about your
atlanta yeah jimmy g over here
overthrowing [ __ ] in the super
bowl man
man i lost a lot of money on the niners
actually man i was sick i was mean to
watch me with a thousand dollars on the
niners to meet the chiefs me and kelly
were there oh yeah you guys were there
you were third row did you have to pay
for those
yeah shout out to the 49ers organization
because it hurts a lot more shouts out
to the organization i always think to
myself like if the cardinals went to the
super bowl and i dropped like 10 bans on
tickets and they lost i'd be [ __ ]
sick
what a bro bro behind us what do you say
he paid
dude i went to this 20 points like two
no three finals games and the sons lost
two of them i was like what the [ __ ] man
goodness i know i know yo
what there was like there was like 12
hunters
i mean they were they were they were
steep for sure but it was it was worth
it i'd be able to say i mean you'd be
able to say you went to a like you know
the last one for like a lot a lot of
years yeah yeah
yeah
yeah the best [ __ ] was i was i was in
person
when this i i hate the [ __ ] clippers
so it was great to see chris paul
set them on fire and send them send them
on send them out at the [ __ ] door
yeah yeah
and then i don't think anyone's a
clippers fan
frankie munez malcolm in the middle is a
clippers fan
billy crystal clippers fan billy klushel
yeah yeah kid inc clippers flip a shirt
i think he's kind of like
clippers fan when it's convenient
he's a clippers fan because they are kid
ink fans i think
he's a lebron fan got you a lot of
people lebron fans i think yes i mean
you're do you hate lebron no i don't i
don't you know what i actually really
respect lebron
and um
you know obviously i'll just be like on
twitter i'll be trolling and [ __ ] and
whatever but but like you got a lot of
you you i i appreciate
how you do stand up to the la [ __ ] on
twitter oh yeah because we both live in
l.a well and it's like we're surrounded
by delusional fans delusional
cook bro they're cooked and by the way
speaking of delusional fans yeah yeah
you're delicious look i need fifty
dollars
my producer he thought he he thought
y'all were gonna win earlier okay but
yeah but like i really what one thing
about lebron bro is like you know him
coming out of high school or whatever
right
he was like really labeled the chosen
one and he [ __ ] followed up and he
he surpassed
any expectations he lived up to the hype
and surpassed it and ain't been involved
in no [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like think about
how hard it is to be lebron and not
be in some scandal with some [ __ ] or
like bro yeah like and and for for him
to do that and then obviously still
continue what he's doing and doing what
he's doing in all aspects is like i
really respect lebron but
the lakers i don't [ __ ] with the lakers
i don't [ __ ] with the lakers i mean i
love kobe bryant though um
jesus christ jesus christ bro why is my
galaxy booming right now you got the
door oh man look at that that's a
commercial right there i got both that's
the comments
that's a commercial let me check this
[ __ ] that is the commercial
baby kev bro two phones
baby kev like baby king
baby cat am i missing the reference yeah
baby king
he always he always be right he got two
phones
yeah
yeah but um i would think kevin gates
would be the obvious reference there oh
kevin gates baby kev
oh wow
kevin gates two phones yeah the the
the both work
double on tanja
it could you know it could be two things
have you uh like now that we're kind of
on the other side of uh
i mean i guess we're kind of on the
other side of the pandemic people are
torn again and [ __ ] but like like how
did that like [ __ ] up your
your like did it did it mess with your
bag at all i mean obviously i think it
messes with a lot of people's bag like
being not being able to tour and do
shows and [ __ ] but you know what i'm
saying it's coming out of this [ __ ] you
know i'm saying
it was it was pretty it was pretty it
was pretty tight just to be able to
get back out inside and like do shows
and
do clubs and [ __ ] like that did you
explore any other like avenues of
revenue or any other things any other
interests while you were you know during
the pen i noticed a lot of artists
started to do [ __ ] like hop on twitch or
like just do other [ __ ] like t-pain's
making so much money on twitch it's
[ __ ] insane yeah like i mean like
i like i thought about it only fans
maybe
yeah actually no i'm kidding um but not
like i thought about it but like really
just like rock
um
but like yeah i don't know if that was
just like what uh what i wanted to do
you know what i'm saying like
um i did get some like i did get some
sync money sync money i mean i mean yeah
yeah what's been like the big sync
moment for you
um
[ __ ] obviously the space jam [ __ ]
um
[ __ ] the eric andre movie which was
really really yeah yeah dude that movie
was hilarious yeah she was insane shout
out to eric andre but yeah like that
[ __ ] um
of blind spotting you know the eric
andre movie was um i've been a fan of
his show for so long
bro i remember one time like uh
my brother had called me and he was like
yeah bro like yeah well like i walked in
the house and um like dad was watching
the eric andre show
and i was like bro my dad is so based
for just like tapping in and just
there's like an episode where
whiz was on there and they brought out
like a naked dude and beat the [ __ ] out
of him
and a dildo shot up no no this was the
ti ver yeah so the ti episode
a guy jumped out of the [ __ ] floor
and see how i jumped up and then a dildo
shot up through the [ __ ] desk and it
and then i was like this is amazing bro
this is insane well it's chaos this is
my kind of show no it's [ __ ] chaos
yeah that's the kind of show i wish i
could do
i've always wanted to do like i've
always wanted to interview like if i i
always wish i wasn't like a veteran in
radio because i've always wanted to
interview somebody
and ask them questions like they were
someone else if that makes sense so like
if i had like chris brown or mario come
in i'd be like yo mario man what was it
like you know run it was my [ __ ] back in
the day
like working with joelle so early what
was that like oh and just be yeah just
just be super off the wall just be
insane but it would never work because
people would be yeah people would like
oh yeah this this [ __ ] is
disrespectful yeah well i want them to
be like that but they would know i'd be
full of [ __ ] because i'm not you know
i needed man i wonder what the budget is
on like a show like erica like [ __ ]
amazing are they just like running it up
and just getting whatever just to do and
then like the rapper games they do like
[ __ ] are getting tased while
they have to run a tightrope and rap
like they got freddy gibbs and joey
badass and all the useful is doing the
wildest [ __ ] bro insane that's crazy
well listen uh
you said hopefully by the springtime
you're gonna get it we're gonna get a
new album yeah possibly you're gonna be
on the mount westmore album um
yeah yeah you got two three songs seven
songs a whole ep with sweetie coming who
knows you're gonna be on the stunner man
remix who knows um
how do you wait wait what other what
other things what other things
i'm trying to think in my head what are
the other things i'd like to see well
he literally
like said everything bro what the [ __ ]
is that
will we ever get
like uh
will we ever resurrect the hbk events
bro who knows bro no one knows
how does that i want to ask you a
question yeah all politics aside how
does it feel to be the guy who like
you know i feel like hbk gang was you
were kind of like
the sixth man of the crew a bit
initially right
shout out to sue great guy but sue was
kind of like the lebron james i would
say you were kind of like
caruso the underrated important piece
that nobody knew was the [ __ ]
until he went to the bulls and then the
lakers fell apart
how does it feel to be like
you're the most relevant popping
[ __ ] from that whole group and
like i feel like you weren't given the
flowers initially in that way
no no i don't even look at it like like
that i think i think it was just the
that
the
that like situation or or the situation
that that i like came up through it was
just to build me
through and to like grow and learn a lot
of things it was a historical movement
out of the baby no i just think it's
dope to see you continuing to level up
yeah i mean i think it's just it's just
a testament to like everything that i
like everything that i learned through
that situation and from those from those
important pieces in my life you know i'm
saying like sue and cool john and sage
and
all of them like you know i'm saying
they all played an important piece to to
what
i'm like continuing to build you know
what i'm saying like i learned a lot of
the a lot of things from those people
what would you say like i
what would you say was your kind of
breakout moment
um
was it what i feel like the first
project like obviously there was the
project you had as a baby with i forget
the name of the product yeah more bits
and more gold chains yeah but i really
[ __ ] loved the movie album yeah no
that was really that's really where it
was it was the move it was the movie
[ __ ]
i feel like that was kind of like yeah
like yeah like that kind of like i mean
like
because because what people really don't
know like a lot of those songs were
movies were just like some [ __ ] i was
just like working on you know what i'm
saying like and then like cool
then i mean coach i'm like oh let's just
do it let's just do a tape so i had like
songs with like one verse on them and
you know and a hook yeah and then just
like john would do hook and then like
there were songs that you know that that
were on the john project that ended up
just like being on movies so we kind of
just like had like a bunch of songs that
we just put together
and um
and they became and then that became
movie and you know what i'm saying and
then from then i was able to pivot for a
movie
into you know what i'm saying like put
me on
and all that stuff so it was like
it was it was what is that your biggest
record is the same squad
oh same same squad's got more streams
right yeah i think yeah i think sam's
crying like same squads like anthem like
all over the place put me on something
like that cali yeah yeah yeah no for
sure same squad like yeah last game yeah
yeah like yeah like i think that's i
think that's obviously i think that's
the bigger song but like yeah man like
i'm excited for what was what's coming
in new [ __ ] coming new ship come in i'm
just trying to see if i can throw
another that's crazy bro how you just
literally bro
what else do i want to hear from this
guy i don't know
tell me what else you want to hear so
because yo man get some more beats from
this guy in a while yeah he he he needs
something you got you got some good
ideas man yeah there it is man you got
some good ideas halo you got this guy
has good ideas man